quand elle rentre dans son centre
d'entraînement la présidente de ce club
canin ne peut que constater les dégâts
on l'a changé je ne sais combien de fois
on compte change plus normalement et
puis si on passe derrière bas ils ont
cassé les fenêtres
et puis selon elle les responsables sont
à quelques dizaines de mètres dans ce
vélodrome
ici une quarantaine de gens du voyage
occupent les lieux depuis la fin de
semaine dernière
c'est là là où ils ont même mis les
parts pas trop moi j'ai constaté samedi
quand on a fait tout le tour mais voilà
ça fait un an que ça dure
ouais alors vite mais tous les deux
trois mois mais là il ya eu juste une
semaine de répit donc là c'est plus
possible
un sentiment partagé au sein du vélo
club d'auxerre car des entraînements
doivent se tenir ici dès le mois de mars
alors le président déplore la situation
toutes les caravanes suivez les unes
derrière les autres et moi j'étais là
impuissant devant le spectacle une
nouvelle fois que dire que faire alors
on est complètement désarçonné cette
communauté de gens du voyage vit depuis
plusieurs années autour d'auxerre ses
membres n'ont pas souhaité nous répondre
face caméra il assure chercher une aire
d'accueil sans succès et pour les dégâts
au club canin
il rejette ces accusations ici il n'ya
pas de jeunes turbulents que des hommes
mariés et des enfants il n'y a pas de
casse quand on se pose quelque part on
ne fait pas de dégradation récemment les
caravanes et leurs habitants ont été
expulsés deux fois sur arrêté
préfectoral d'auxerre expo et du
vélodrome
la mairie d'auxerre à qui appartient le
terrain demande de nouveau leur départ